Can we take the biblical,
Andrew Wells asks,
can we take the biblical story seriously enough with those without also keeping
biblical traditions?
What's the psychological impact of group gathering church going?
I think we could take the biblical stories seriously enough,
but I don't think that it's particularly easy.
Um,
the traditions bind the community together.
Now I'm saying that and I don't go to church,
you know,
and the reason I don't go to church is because while it drives me crazy to
speak,
frankly,
I haven't been able to sit in a situation like that ever since I was,
whatever.
Really.
That's really the truth of it ever.
Um,
I'm not convinced that that's a good thing because I do believe and I've had
good conversations about this with Jonathan Patio,
I do believe that communal return to the source of the community's ethics is
actually a necessary thing.
And maybe I'm atoning for my past sins by doing these biblical lectures at the
moment,
which is something that's communal.
So,
and then because there's also something about going where a bunch of other
people are to reaffirm your commitment to,
to the good that you're all aiming at,
that's got some power in it.
And,
and I don't think that that's something that we should forgo.
I think it's dangerous.
I mean,
look,
even if you're cynical about church and I guess I would put myself in that
category,
it's certainly the case that communal church going in the 19 fifties say,
provided the average person with at least an hour a week where they were
contemplating no matter how poorly the purpose of ethics in life and,
and the idea of a higher purpose and higher meaning in life.
And you got to think that spending an hour a week thinking about that is better
than never doing it at all.
So I don't know how to,
that tradition can be revivified in a meaningful way,
but I think it's.
I really do think it's a catastrophe that we've lost it because we don't have a
center,
an ethical center that holds our community together.
And the consequence of that is that we're fragmenting quite badly.
So.